juicy to share to do that you guys you
know you heard about Kim jong-il and Kim
Kim Jong Un's brother being educated
right with that nerve gas as it turns
out you know those two women thought
that they were in a game show and that
they were spraying someone's face as
like a prank because they somebody hello
no no so these two women had previously
been paid money to prank people to spray
stuff in their face phrasing yeah and so
they didn't know because when the mother
came out and talked about one of the her
daughter who was one of the suspects I
was like look she's a provincial girl
like she would never be an assassin of
that sort right so okay so let me get so
let me just hear what you're saying yeah
I have it what's it called the sugar
film okay good thank you you didn't
watch it yet no we got to watch it okay
yeah poison sugar yeah poison okay but
that's exactly that's the announcement I
want to make sugar is poison okay so let
me get this straight kalila these two
chinks not trying to use Bo
they're not Chinese I think they are
actually well they were in Malaysia so
it could be anything
yeah Kings Kings changed some checks
christop singh chinks over and over and
looking at all of us these two chicks
that were Malaysian that's how you say
it by the Royal yeah Malaysian or in
Australia
Urmila
so some man or a group of manga hey you
guys want to be in a react like a prank
show though which what will a call
it's called spray in face yeah okay so
they gave them squirt for guns at first
or something tonight so they probably
set up cameras just to because their
ultimate goal is says assassinate the
brother yeah
so they sprayed it you know man they
paid him some money right and then when
kim jeong-hoon steps off the plane this
is the guy you have to prank so they
gave her him Kim jong-nam they gave him
a gun filled with poison yeah
like a like an equivalent to like nerve
gas nerve gas and then they sprayed it
in his face yeah I thought they wiped it
on his face no well there's like
conflicting reports about whether or not
he was grabbed or whatnot but one of the
girls actually thought that she was even
gonna get flown to China for a comedy
show afterwards for like some TV comedy
thing that's [ __ ] that's like that
you know that's like that's like the
show black mirror but also isn't that a
really good excuse yeah yeah but can
they just say that though can they go we
thought we were on TV I mean that's what
I'm saying like they could just say that
and they could have the guy's
corroborate that story too I think
they'll still do jail time though it
doesn't matter I don't think it matters
I don't that's that's a weak excuse even
if it's real you're a [ __ ] idiot and
but then the weirder part stop sub sub
sub stop so let me just say this uh-huh
okay okay let's suppose I get hard to go
to a prank show all right
steve-o calls me Steve go steve-o goes
you wanna do a prank show
why don't I got nothing else to do think
he knew this Chinese producer guy so if
like a week they pay us under the table
we're spraying people in the face and
all of a sudden they then one day they
go you guys sprayed that white dude Oh
in the face and I spray them in the face
and it's poison and then all of a sudden
I'm in the rod Lowe that killed Rob Lowe
right and then you think I deserve to go
to prison yeah I feel like if there's
like I mean you're just because you're
so dumb you know I mean yeah this
[ __ ] show and this guy had a wife and
this is like one of those forensic foul
type shows right me to watch him all but
this guy was on he had a wife he had two
kids he wanted the kids to himself and
he wanted to divorce his wife but he
didn't want to have to deal with all
that [ __ ] so he wanted to kill the wife
so he would play video games like 12
hours a day like he was like you know he
didn't like you do and so he would make
friends with other people with the
[ __ ] you know on a lot yeah yeah so
he made friends with this one guy
they're probably the wife went out of
town and
he had the guy come over and they would
hang out and they were friends and they
were new you know new friends and they
were new friends for a while and he
would end up coming over every now and
then and then he talked him into he was
like we should both get the same haircut
so they went to go get the same haircut
and then he was like listen I'm gonna be
out of town I'm gonna be out of town but
I want you to stay at my place and weed
and wear my clothes and everything
whatever and so the guy who [ __ ] wore
all of his clothes yeah well while the
husband went and found his wife wherever
she was and killed his wife and then
came back and then but there was video
footage of him in his clothes I was
important but it was the [ __ ] guy he
told to get the same haircut as himself
and oh right right now and a guy who I
think he went to jail the guy did yeah
because he's a [ __ ] idiot like your
dog yeah yeah no one died you should go
to prison just were you guys close and
getting the haircut a haircut it's weird
it's like Chris go like with you know
wear this wig this Bruce yeah
Springfield haircut at what point
wouldn't wouldn't you be like weird you
do it and then the guys like I wear my
clothes while I'm out of town that is
the moment where I'm like okay you're
gonna go kill someone I think or
something I don't want to do that yeah
you're right yes
either it's that or he said listen I'm
gonna go kill my wife I need you to
[ __ ] well yeah but at that point he's
now but but that's like how do you prove
to the cops one way or another I agree
with you just it just in case he's just
go to prison just in case yeah yeah
because I would never be in that
situation is it true that they have that
new Russian survival game show where
like rape and murder is actually allowed
or is that I mean that can't be true but
that would be amazing
why it's like
as everything else is over from then on
we're done yeah that's real that's the
last thing and if there's a game show
where you can get a raise then it's it
your that's it
we're done as a society that's it that's
it but the Russians but do I still get
in the after if I'm raped you silly like
do I still am I in the Union and they're
like you need two more points oh you're
lucky you're lucky
you almost got rave to put you're not
sag eligible yeah yeah also Russian
reality TV show called Game two to allow
rape and murder in Siberia I don't I
don't believe the Guardian yeah would
you watch it no no a hundred percent no
no way those two thousand cameras nine
hundred hectares our Hector Hector
hectares ninety nine hundred guys named
Hector
[Laughter]
okay so thirty lives everything or the
loud fighting alcohol murder rape
smoking anything they have to sign a
waiver something right now the girls - I
think this 13 says Malin wit Malin all
right so basically you're saying is is
that if there's 15 men and 15 women 15
women get raped well there's gonna be a
few Hector's we're like oh my MA hurts
all right yeah that's crazy so the
landscape is with bears and wolves was
just the wildlife
[Music]